joining us here from Turner Sports fresh
off of his honorary captain see this
weekend is Chris Webber
how are you see wet how was the weekend
how was it oh it was incredible it was
there was incredible man dime I don't
know if Ali was just humbling just just
appreciated coach Harbaugh so much for
one let me come speak to the team and
talk to those young guys you know in
some way you know get the seed of a
division store you know up close and I
got to do that by watching them practice
and I was just just impressed with our
discipline each each individual was I
was impressed with just how each player
since our focus that practice was I
literally you do not even the practice
that they're gonna then destroy them
because they didn't remember last year's
loss so he was incredible all got
because talked with coach Brown and
speaking with him was just I mean when
he gives you chills out the dog
inspiring makes you want to go play
football
I'm be a defensive player so it was cool
man I'm just overly thanks to coach
Harbaugh for inviting me to be around
the son of the men being out there my
father with the corn was just it was
just a cool moment so it's something
that you know and they're just you know
actually no words for losses losses in
just cool what you tell the team Chris I
just was about them you know it's just
about them and you know the lessons that
you learned in college did it taste it
you're gonna have to go through your
whole life so might as well get used to
and Marco you a couple weeks ago they
want to coach farm they wanted all of
you off and you couldn't play as a
quarterback defense we look good and all
this stuff they're a de jure or not if
they like us we're gonna go out there in
that egg right you know we look good and
all the girls like a good coach and all
people are on the bandwagon or just do
something stupid right and no because
people are gonna jump off the bandwagon
even when you win you know it's about
the consistency of effort in life's
things you doing no one sees you exactly
you can use this all of the motivation
but it don't mean nothing unless you get
your final goal and
you know you can look yourself anymore
so you did all good doing you know they
already we're ahead of it on infinity
think inspired that they inspired me
because you know because of the way that
they prepared and how that they bounced
back and didn't listen to everything I
learn or see anything on the periphery
they keep that blind is gonna just keep
focusing that's all we talked about this
life people jump one off the bandwagon
stay the same person and keep giving the
same well I mean one of the things that
Harbaugh told me to Chris is that you
got an ovation on par with that of Tom
Brady I'm wondering how that felt
for you to be on the campus of Ann Arbor
and feeling that from from Michigan fans
and faithful Chris well you know I went
to the arena with her Stadium with some
people had never been there and they've
been with some pretty big ten arenas you
know big tennis stadiums and so first of
all just imagining the mountain dannis
$2,100 people come nothing beside being
in that state in tonight hundred
thousand people for you know so just
imagine Ireland first of all and then to
be in the middle that then to be shown
the middle guy is I know I don't know
honey I don't know how to quantify honor
I won't it's surreal as long as I like
insane so there's a gate screaming
abusing her great to me just it just
doesn't do it justice all I'm really
good looking for the words or phrase
that really can summon up but just if
you could just imagine being in front of
that many people number one there get
off stop by their presence
I see a blue amazing blue and then man
is showing off is this but I mean just
seeing you just just seeing you in in
Michigan gear I'm again I'm just I'm not
taking my you know host and show hat off
now you're speaking on behalf of
Michigan Wolverines Chris seeing you in
the Michigan gear seeing you accepting
accepting love okay it's not just
receiving it it's accepting it from you
it meant a lot to me I'm wondering what
it meant to you and how you feel about
the University in the athletic program
now as you and i are chatting well it's
always meant a lot to me because I've
always accepted love from the fans and
there's no way I cannot rub the
admission because I am Michigan just
like the good things man in the
basketball team is Michigan's our
psychic student and the English
department is Michigan so it's it's been
a complicated relationship but anyone
who's gone to Michigan it's more than
being an employee at the University of
Michigan I'm saying that you're saying
something else that he didn't go there
is just it's just the difference so I'm
walking around Michigan all these years
being a Michigan all these years it's
been awesome my whole life I there's
nothing I've never once shy away so I
was nothing I've never not wanted to be
a part of so is this not not on me
not accepting love so coming back and
being a part of it physics is just
awesome man I mean I don't I hope that
we Susan coming across any other way
than being gates or humble it is really
even overwhelming is anything that's not
even a good up words just it was an
awesome awesome moment and just you know
I've been on a visitor mission I think
1989 or 88 and I got to see the greatest
football games out knocking still
running back there now Charlotte's
making instructions on official business
so you know when we recruited to
Michigan you included about a football
squad first cuz you go there and in the
fall there you see how big the campus is
you're right you can make a game that
next day and so just brought back so
many of those you know memories you know
I know
I knew Bo Schembechler very well and
long before to the end of the time off
so when people talk about boys it's cool
but he was a friend you know I mean so I
mean I'm you know to know you know coach
Harbaugh inviting back well to see the
pitch up like Greg scrub Knicks in the
hallways Happiny Carter and then to see
you know you know the video or to come
the tunnel to see the band I hope you
know I'm not trying to be cool because
this situation is really between I think
think me and God about I'm very
appreciative him allowing me to be in
the situation but it was just images of
Tony awesome moment I'm sorry any fans
but I felt like I wasn't accepted in
love and hopefully one day I was
explains and move on but it has never
been that way because if anything I
think when people took a look at it
might have been different and so this
was a wonderful moment and I'm
appreciative and I just I don't I don't
know I I mean I don't know if anything
can get much better than that and being
in that place see in that game seeing
the wind and I've already talked to you
about being nervous you know about you
know this thing about this after they
lost the Notre Dame game is when I
decided what game I go to mmm people
were down on the team we said the team
wasn't good they were talking about
tuition that and I picked the Penn State
game because I was like if we went act
if we get to this game undefeated we win
it that's exactly what I said and the
key was talking to it like I don't know
you think it's a good thing they go
three and four you know you can get you
know what I mean like yeah again took a
risk on it for real right and so I'm
just happy to be part of it to see this
revenge tour in person and for the team
to accept me because it's the thing to
Richard and maybe maybe this is I told
the guys it's all about them this
weekend and now I can't really talk
about it because I did have a good time
but I just want to make sure during the
weekend it was about them and in no way
try to overshadow what they want to
order be a distraction not to be a
practice too long that's be feel too
long because I was them like at the end
of the day I'm still a athlete and I
know you can inspire me and get the hell
out the way so we can get the business
you know how me in general you know that
that was my goal in but I'm just I'm
thankful and the love I received from
the fans it's nothing that's better than
that because that's who I play for
that's who I did it for that's who won
with this that's who cheered with this
doesn't cried with this when we lost and
so that moment of going through the
tailgates being there with the fans
walking through the campus playing beer
pong with a couple of students it was it
was I mean
you know I was the first one on the
sophomore all over again because during
those years I was at the football games
I was running around I was just doing so
I was reliving those moments a time
that's awesome
Chris before I let you go I would be
remiss if I didn't ask you about the
news over the weekend that leaked out to
woge of ESPN that magic sat down with
Luke Walton and admonished him since
then magic has said that they did in
fact chat that Luke heard him but
everything's all good he's going to be
the coach of this team for the season
what do you think about this news and
whether it's warranted the chat and what
the Lakers start is based again in light
of you saying prior to the season you
didn't think they'd be making the plows
yeah well first of all think magic is a
man so whatever he wants you know
whether it was in his career and after
the first year winning championship and
then Pat Riley coming in other things
you know he's someone that I trust his
basketball acumen and whether he
believes and Luke or not unfortunately
I'm not there and so I would trust him
blindly on what what he sees and I'm
sure that the players know they don't
have an import input in the office I'm
sure that their body language or the way
they practice and respond things amid we
don't see I'm sure has a large role in
that but again I think they have to make
a trade before the I think that liquor
trading for the playoffs I saw a
statistic today something crazy where
their cluster - with the myth without
LeBron and I don't think that of course
is not based on him but again and maybe
based upon the type of talent you know
that you put around and you know you put
some guards around Tom Brady no
disrespect to the Lakers because the
guys a lot of time Brady - can't catch
probably won't be that good you know
what I'm saying so I think you need
shooters around him and to open the
taint up and so yeah I'm still you know
I saw them get beat down last night but
it didn't surprise me at all and if you
really think about it I know this is
gonna sound crazy but on a team where
LeBron is the MVP if it was not for
JaVale McGee of course the Bonner the
MVP of the team the best player
blah blah blah but if it wasn't for
javale mcgee on decent and shot blocking
shots where would they be and so I think
that you got to address that before you
see maybe he doesn't have a standard to
finish or a vapor injury or something
else to that point these young kids are
good they're going to be good players
they're going to have really long
careers but you're talking about the
timing of the window of four years and
show if I was LA I would not make a
trade I would wait and just kill the
summer but I don't know if the
expectations that's been built up or the
family that's been built up by everyone
there's fans of the Lakers including
those in the media that want the Lakers
to go so they can just support their or
go to the finals there or or just want
the NBA to be back in that way I think
that I just think that all those things
you know really distort the truth of the
Lakers maybe not having a talent it
depends on some teams like San Antonio
it depends on some teams like Portland
and others to see what they can do but I
still think they're going to have to
make a trade but again I wouldn't and
that's kind of my kind of pinging on the
Lakers you don't think it's it so you're
not looking at this team Chris Webber
and saying this is a poorly coach team
through the first nine games I know I
just I don't think that I think they've
scorned scorer decide to paint I just
don't think that I'm I don't know why he
was good enough you know sir Costa team
in the beginning and not now accept the
fact that once the magic comes in you do
have the right to have your business and
that has nothing to do with necessarily
how well or how poorly he's done it's
more about implementing decision I don't
think even if he really gets fired I
don't think it would be I know how we
proceed this is for of course but I
don't think within the basketball
society I don't think magic would be
directly said this is your fault by just
be saying you know I have a different
vision of the team or how I want the
team to be communicated to or I or
vision and so I think he has the right
to do that because ultimately magically
the greatest thing by going against
there one of the greatest creators of
all time in getting the Brawn and then
you know they have some business I need
to attend to so they have a plan and I
would trust that over over anyone elses
well
thanks for the call great honorary
captain see Chris you know I'm gonna be
honest with you
you didn't you nailed it when they
called tails and he came here and I was
like wait wait who caught the other
class I was like okay first question is
go to church okay second pressure so I
was walking around there nervous man but
uh a minute man it was no feeling like
it man
there's no feeling like it it's a memory
of a lifetime I I can't express how
thankful I am to the fans I think slam
to the coach I think find everyone there
so it meant so much so we'll see you
back in Ann Arbor soon oh yeah oh yeah
it's over now I mean this you know I'm
gonna make sure that uh definitely did
some more football games and again I
think and I hope this is the first of a
number of a long relationship because
that's what I have to be about a
relationship not just about um you know
not just about about a handshake and
that's why you know it was really cool
that a friend and ex alum or an alum of
Michigan and the athlete they're um kind
of you know hopefully help you start to
build that bridge and I'm humbled I'm
grateful and I'm just looking forward to
many more great opportunities like that
and I hope this is the start of
beginning okay Chris that's great to
hear man I'm I'm fired up
I'm fired up well done way to end and we
got a run through the table to rest this
guy so I know they don't think we could
be that Alabama but you know Chris Chris
Chris there's Ohio State for crying out
loud I know and I'm not speaking before
but see that's what now I'm saying you
know knock I could speak before that
they got to stay focused I'm saying all
right see Webb take care Congrats again
on a great in on a great weekend again
Harbaugh said you were first class you
spoke to everybody you shook every hand
you took every picture he said you had a
blast and it was great having you around
the team well coach all of them and so
you thanks a lot I appreciate it right
back at you Saint got go blue right
there for Chris Webber just signed off
go below that just happened the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience